welcome to this video playing ashram
okay got a Scottish gambit amazed that
people still play this so rather well
known actually that this is quite good
for black now but okay people still play
that yeah g5 looks strange but I have 95
coming and this secures the night only
fire from white ride really is in some
trouble here the only issue is that in
in blitz chess it's kind of a messy
position so you can screw up but its own
it's some from the purely analytical
point of view this is an almost
unplayable variation but ok let's see
what what happens in the intellectual in
the actual game
so he's going there why where is he
going ok made on her seven I was close
to play night back to f6 yeah I should
do that one ok so if i go Queen f6 he's
taking on b7 probably so night if five
maybe 95 platform hmm
huh interesting let's see how to do that
Queen f6 is not great p7 hangs
this F for move I find really irritating
95f form I do a play Knight f6 then mm
fe5 night h5 and that looks very weird
mmm it's the way to cover this Queen d7
but that runs into Bishop g4 ok so let's
play that
a form that really irritates me a lot
if it's not playing a forever I mean I
have no I have six the next move so and
for looks yeah that that's that's really
really strange takes Bishop takes Queen
h4 maybe for a double attack but 95 and
sorry Bishop b5 I mean
it might go to g3 half Knight f6 which
is at least speeding up my development
or not but that's it's amazingly
complicated is retreatin okay so
fetching check should age six is somehow
also part of the equation sometimes plan
we're very complicated and what is this
actually equal material right oh
the bishop h5 remove 10 minutes it's
quite cool yeah I only knew the position
up to g5 and all them all the books say
black is some black is clearly better
that might be true it might be true but
it is it is still fairly complicated
okie dokie can I just take F 2 here or
something i'm also up for Queen f6 now I
mean I have the better piece
mobilization the only issue of my please
my king is also quite open he's playing
without night and rukia but it's all a
very kind of shaky of this this whole
whole position getting in Queen h4 would
be nice so yeah sure take with the night
or with the rook rook is this check so
probably not
I mean it is mmm this night is an
awkward chick f3
and three what is my move after that
night f2 takes Bishop takes Bishop h6
chick oh I did not think about this move
at all ok queen edge for looks like the
move I want to play yeah covering h6
that's very important
and that will take on f2 unfortunately
it's not winning
very ah very complicated only if you can
simply
I did not expect this movement in this
kind of position are you probably it's
hard to how to really calculate what do
now take here I cannot take them d5
Queen checks it's not working for take
it we're taking it time more opens my
position quite a lot better check didn't
even see the check Wow check check on
flu way check
and now they know my phone is ringing
Jeff
you
but unfortunately it's not as not
difficult anymore meeting him
I come on I'm going to take this call
later okay and roop g8 is coming I can
pre move that wow that was tough white
forfeits on time yeah Brooke g8 check
mate check or can desperado check check
and check mate and then it's made yeah
let's check let's check back to this
opening line Bishop to age five yeah
while looking at it it just make lots of
sense but the computer actually gives a
huge advantage to white and am i
confusing things I think this is the
position really
hmm huh I'm going to look that up let me
let me check i have i have the book YTM
bolo gone book let me check that let me
check c3 okay okay okay I can few things
yeah okay i confuse things in fact there
is this line and now g5 is excellent ha
ok it does make lots of sense actually
and now sometimes g4 will really good
here with the rook on the G file and
yeah that looks fine and to hear I have
to play Knight f6 just develop and go
from there with unclear consequences why
the book says slightly better for black
but ok it's hard to say no but this was
my mistake i mean i confuse things and
now i really was in trouble yeah i feel
felt like that I was kind of questioning
myself because I thought that this after
g5 I'm good but it was the other line i
confused things yeah now I really have
problems pretty pretty clearly so we
went here here and now can form the comp
wants to go here actually and says 1.7
hmm yeah my king position is just bad
yeah my king position is bad this Bishop
here is super awkward it covers the
weakness and it's always looking at this
chick mating square so Jeff and this
this was all right this was quick I was
expecting fe5 actually but he didn't do
that
it was stronger it's the computer line
with a clear advantage gr my king is
just super loose and here comes s about
equal night XD for snow good for black
ha now it's a it's at it's hard to play
here here 92 queen age from Bishop d3
queen age five year and he gives white a
pretty big advantage one pawn yeah my
king is just so weak but what happened
now this was certainly neither three I
thought this should be okay for me and
somehow know if I have cheeks this this
no I'm okay c6 and now check yeah here
he is in slight slight trouble because
night the captures on f2 now I'm an idea
again and this was just losing right
yeah this is immediately losing due to
this checkmate this checkmating sequence
yeah this is sometimes can happen in
those in those very sharp openings with
e4 e5 in this old airlines sometimes
they are not really great but you have
to remember things correctly which is
not really a problem in tournament chess
i think in tournament chess you probably
will recognize that g5 bishop h5 is kind
of awkward but in blitz sometimes you
stumble into those problematic lines and
then you have to handle it with very
little time on the clock okay that was a
fun game nevertheless thanks for
watching